สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 25
เดือนอะไรคะ
ใช่ไหมไหม
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 26 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2003 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
บ่ายโมง
บ่ายโมงกี่นาทีตรง
บ่ายโมงตรงใช่ไหมตอนนี้เป็นเวลาบ่ายโมง
ตรงครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังคะบ่ายโมงแล้ว
บ่ายโมงแล้วกินข้าวแล้วค่ะคุณหญิง
เพราะว่าเดี๋ยวกินข้าวเสร็จแล้วบ่ายโมง
ครูฟ้ามีอะไรต้องทำอีกไหมคะ
ก็ทำงานค่ะ
[เพลง]
ทุกคนเนี่ยตอนนี้ครูฟ้าบ่ายโมงครูฟ้าอยู่
ที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะแล้วค่อยออกไปทำงานแต่คน
ส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยเขาก็จะทำงานตั้งแต่ 9 โมง
เช้าจนถึง 6 โมงเย็น
แล้วทำงานเสร็จแล้วตอนเย็นเป็นเวลาเย็นๆ
ใช่ไหมตอนเย็นถึง
กลับบ้าน
แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำงานตอนเย็นสมัยตั้งแต่
กี่โมงคะ 5 โมงใช่ไหมคะ
ตั้งแต่ 4 โมงค่ะ
เพราะว่าพอเริ่ม 4 โมงเนี่ยก็เป็นตอนเย็น
แล้วไงประเทศไทยมันจะร้อนน้อยลงแล้วก็ตอน
เย็นเนี่ยครูฟ้าถึงจะทำงานแล้วก็เลิกดึก
ใช่ไหมคะ 4 ทุ่มใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเลิกงาน
4 ทุ่มค่ะบางทีเพิ่งถึงบ้าน 4 ทุ่มครึ่ง
เห็นไหมคุณฟ้าก็เลิกงานดึกแต่คนส่วนใหญ่
เนี่ยเขาจะเลิกงานตอนเย็นหรือว่าถ้าเป็น
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ซัก 4 โมงเย็นเนี่ย
เป็นช่วงตอนเย็นอากาศที่ไทยเนี่ยไม่ร้อน
มากเอาคนไทยนะครูฟ้าคิดว่าตอนเย็นๆเนี่ย
ตั้งแต่ 4 โมงเย็น
คนไทยชอบทำอะไรตอนเย็นๆคือไม่รู้ว่า
นักเรียนไปอะไรนะคะครูฟ้าตั้งแต่ 4 โมง
เย็นเป็นต้นไปหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะตั้งแต่เพราะว่าถ้าเป็นตอนเช้าเนาะ
6 โมงจนถึง 8 โมงอันนี้ตอนเช้าแต่ถ้า
เป็นตอนเที่ยง
ก็ตอนกลางวันใช่ไหมคะแต่ที่ครูฟ้าแต่เวลา
ตอนนี้ก็คือบ่ายโมงจนถึงบ่าย 3 โมงเนี่ย
ตอนบ่ายเนี่ยทำงานทำงาน
ร้อนหรือว่าถ้าอยู่บ้าน
ก็นอน
อยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านเพราะว่าอากาศมันร้อนแต่
พอซัก 4 โมงเย็นเนี่ยตอนเย็นๆมันร้อนน้อย
ลงไงบางครั้งเนี่ย
ไม่ตอนเช้าไม่ทำอะไรตอนกลางวันไม่ทำอะไร
ตอนบ่ายไม่ทำอะไรแต่พอถึงช่วงเย็นๆ
อาจจะอยากคิดอยากจะทำอะไรก็เลยอยากถามครู
ฟ้าว่าครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนไทยชอบทำอะไรตอนเย็น
คิดได้ 1 อย่างนะคะ
มีหลายอย่างมากเลยนะ
คนไทยชอบทำอะไรตอนเย็นกินข้าว
เดี๋ยวตอนเช้าตอนกลางวันคนไทยไม่กินข้าว
หรอคะคนไทยกินข้าว 4 โมงเย็นหรอตอนเย็น
เท่านั้น 4 โมง 5 โมง 6 โมงเป็นตอนเย็นคน
ไทยกินข้าวตอนเย็นหรอ
ตอนเช้าก็กินตอนกลางวันก็กินแต่ตอนเช้า
เนี่ยบางที 6 โมงผิดนะคะนักเรียน
6 โมงเช้า 7:00 นมีเวลากินข้าวนิดหน่อย
ไง
หรือว่าตอนที่เที่ยงก็ต้องมีเวลากินข้าว
นิดหน่อยต้องทำงานแต่เป็นถึงเวลาตอนเย็น
เนี่ยโอ้โหทำงานเสร็จแล้ว
เรียนเสร็จแล้วใช่ไหมคะกลับบ้านมีเวลา
เยอะที่ครูฟ้าบอกว่ากินข้าวก็คือกินเยอะๆ
กินอาหารที่อร่อยที่เราอยากกินเราจะทำ
อะไรคะเราจะทำในช่วงตอนเย็นๆครูพอกันนะคะ
ก็เลยคิดว่ากินข้าวนะคะเพราะทุกๆคนต้อง
กินข้าวเย็นใช่ไหมบางคนก็ไม่กินข้าวเย็น
นั้นก็โอเคนะไม่เป็นไรแต่บางคนก็ต้องกิน
อาหารเย็นกินข้าวเย็นก็อาจจะกินตอน
6 โมง
ใช่กินตอนเย็นแล้วแบบคือก่อนกินเนี่ย
สมมุติว่าจะกินข้าวเย็นสัก 1 ทุ่มแต่คือ 1
ทุ่มมันก็ไม่ได้เย็นแล้วเนาะมันก็เริ่ม
มืดๆแล้วนะคะแต่พอกลับมาถึงบ้านตอนเย็นก็
ได้ทำอาหารไงตอนเช้าอาหารเช้าเนี่ยอาจจะ
ซื้อ
แซนด์วิชขนมปังใช่ไหมกินขนมปังนิดหน่อย
กินง่ายๆตอนกลางวันก็เดินแล้วก็ไปซื้ออัน
นี้เดินนะคะนักเรียนแล้วก็ไปซื้อกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เร็วๆแต่ถ้าเป็นตอนเย็นเนี่ยมีเวลามากๆก็
อาจจะทำอาหาร
เพราะเริ่มตั้งแต่ไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตคน
ไทยชอบไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตตอนเย็นนะนัก
เรียนเพราะว่าเลิกงานแล้วก็ไป Supermarket
แล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงก็คือ Supermarket ตอน
เย็นเนี่ยบางครั้งเนี่ยของมันจะถูกถ้าครู
ฟ้าไปซื้อตอนเช้าสมมุติ
แครอท
1 หัวตอนเช้าอาจจะ 20 บาท
แต่พอตอนเย็นก็จะลดลงเหลือ 15 บาทอย่าง
นี้บางอย่างไงหลายๆคนก็ตอนเย็นปุ๊บเดินไป
Supermarket ซื้อของแล้วก็กลับบ้านทำ
อาหารเย็นกินข้าวเย็นแบบโอ้โหกินเยอะมาก
ในตอนเย็นกินอะไรอร่อยๆในตอนเย็น
คนไทยชอบกินอาหารเย็นนะคะเยอะๆ
เลยเมนูในหัวเพียบ
เมนู
แต่ตอนเช้าตอนกลางวันบางทีไม่คิดจะกิน
อะไรก็คือกินอะไรก็ได้แต่พอตอนเย็นจะคิด
เย็นนี้กินอะไรจะเป็นคำถามที่เราจะคุยกัน
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็เลยคิดว่าคนต้องกินแน่นอน
ค่ะ
ตอนเย็น
แต่ถ้าบางคนที่เหมือนครูฟ้าบอกว่าบางคน
เขาก็กินนิดหน่อยหรือไม่กินเนี่ยเพราะว่า
ตอนเย็นเนี่ยเขาก็จะไปออกกำลังกายไงไป
ฟิตเนส
อันนี้จะวาดได้หรือเปล่านะคะนักเรียน
นี่แล้วก็อยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหม
แล้วก็อันนี้
ไปวิ่งใช่ไหมอาจจะไปฟิตเนสไปฟิตเนสก็จะมี
ลู่วิ่งอันนี้เข้าใจไหมคะนักเรียนกดตรง
นี้ใช่ไหม
กดแล้วอันนี้มันก็จะหมุนแล้วคุณก็จะวิ่ง
วิ่งวิ่ง
อยู่ในนี้นะลู่วิ่งหรือว่ามีดัมเบล
ยกดัมเบลเนี่ยไปออกกำลังกายหรือบางคนก็ไป
ที่สวนนะคะ
มีต้นไม้ใช่ไหมมีสวนอ่าตรงนี้ก็จะมีแบบ
เวที
แล้วก็มีคนยืนแล้วนี่ก็มีคนคน
เต้นแอโรบิค
เขาเต้นแอโรบิคไง
ที่ไทยเนี่ยคือคิดว่านักเรียนไม่รู้นัก
เรียนจะชอบเต้นแอโรบิคตอนเช้าหรือตอนเย็น
แต่ถ้าไทยนะคะในสวนหรือว่าบางทีข้างหน้า
ข้างหน้า Supermarket  Supermarket ใช่
มั้ยบางทีมันจะมีลานข้างหน้าตรงนี้ที่เรา
เอาไว้จอดรถเวลานักเรียนขับรถมาแล้วมันก็
จะจอดรถได้
พอตอนเย็นซัก 6 โมงเย็นเนี่ยบางทีเขาก็จะ
ไม่มีเขาจะแบ่งนิดหน่อยตรงนี้แล้วก็มี
เวที
แล้วก็มีคนไปยืนแล้วก็มีคนคนๆๆเต้น
แอโรบิคอยู่ข้างหน้าพวกซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
นะคะจะเห็นเยอะมากๆวันที่ไทยเนี่ยเย็นๆ
เนี่ยมันร้อนน้อยไงคนก็จะไปออกกำลังกาย
ตอนเย็นฟิตเนสเนี่ยอาจจะไปตอนไหนก็ได้แต่
ถ้าเต้นแอโรบิคหรือว่าไปสวนเนี่ยจะไปออก
กำลังกายตอนเย็นครูฟ้าเคยออกกำลังกายไหม
คะ
คือค่ะนักเรียนคะ
ถึงครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะดูเป็นคนที่แบบว่า
ไม่ออกกำลังกาย
ครูฟ้าไม่ออกกำลังกายแต่ครูฟ้าออกกำลัง
กายนะคะเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าเป็นคนออกกำลังกายตอนเช้า
หรือว่าตอนเย็น
ครูฟ้าออกกำลังกายตอนเย็นค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็เหมือนกันนะคะผู้หญิงก็เคยคิด
อยากจะตื่นนอน 7 โมงเช้าแล้วก็ 8 โมงไป
ออกกำลังกายตอนเช้า
แต่ไม่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนผู้หญิงก็เลยเลื่อน 4
โมงเย็นออกกำลังกายออกกำลังกายตอนเย็น
ครูฟ้าเลือกออกกำลังกาย 6 โมงเย็น
ก็ได้ค่ะแล้วแต่
เดี๋ยวนอนไม่ได้นะครูฟ้าออกกำลังกาย 6
โมงถึง 1 ทุ่มพอแล้ว 1 ชั่วโมงพอแล้ว
[เพลง]
ก็ได้แล้ว
นอกจากออกกำลังกายเนี่ยค่ะ
ยังมีเลยที่ทำตอนเย็นอีกไหมคะ
มีค่ะอันนี้
คนไทยก็ชอบทำตอนเย็นเพราะประเทศไทยมัน
ร้อนเหมือนกัน
นะคะไม่รู้ก็พูดได้ค่ะ
ความไม่ยอมนะ
ไม่รู้ครูฟ้าต้องตอบไม่ได้แน่ๆเลย
ทำตอนเย็น
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำตอน
เย็นไหม
แต่คิดว่าหลายๆคนกลับจากที่ทำงานว่าจะ
อยู่บ้านหรือว่าอยู่คอนโดมาอยู่คอนโด
เนี่ยบางครั้งคอนโดมันจะมีวาดไม่เป็นนะคะ
มีตรงนี้ระเบียงยื่นออกมา
มองไม่เห็นนะคะนักเรียน
สมัยบางคนมีระเบียงยื่นออกมาตรงนี้ก็จะมี
กระถางต้นไม้และก็ปลูกต้นไม้ใช่ไหมหรือ
ว่ามีดอกไม้หรือว่าที่บ้านอย่างนี้ก็จะมี
สวนใช่ไหมมีหญ้ามีดอกไม้มีดอกไม้คนไทย
เนี่ยจะชอบรดน้ำต้นไม้ตอนเย็นค่ะบางคนอาจ
จะมีเป็นปลั๊กแบบนี้ด้วยเป็นก๊อกน้ำแล้ว
ก็มีสายยาง
[เพลง]
รดน้ำต้นไม้หรือว่ามีเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
อะไรคะ
รดน้ำต้นไม้
อันนี้อาจจะใช้หรือว่ามีสเปรย์ก็ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนเป็นขวดแบบพวกฟ๊อกซี่อ่ะ
เราเนี่ยจะชอบรดน้ำต้นไม้ตอนเย็นเพราะว่า
ตอนเย็นเนี่ยมันไม่ร้อนคือตอนเช้าก็ไม่
ร้อนนะคะนักเรียนแต่ถ้าส่วนใหญ่วันจันทร์
ถึงวันศุกร์เนี่ยตอนเช้าเราต้องรีบไปทำ
งานไงพอกลับมาบ้านตอนเย็นอากาศมันไม่ร้อน
หรืออยู่บ้านถ้าเที่ยง
เที่ยงเนี่ยมันร้อนมากๆเราก็ไม่รดน้ำต้น
ไม้ใช่ไหมต้นไม้จะตาย
ก็เลยรดน้ำต้นไม้ตอนเย็น
ใช่ค่ะ
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าตามต้นไม้ตอนเย็นไหมคะ
ตอนเช้าค่ะ
นักเรียนก็อาจจะบอกเหมือนกันว่าตอนเช้า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ถ้าคุณหญิงจะรดน้ำต้นไม้
ของผู้หญิงอยู่คอนโดแล้วปลุกต้นไม้ที่นี่
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้ตอนเช้าเหมือนกันนะรถตอน
เย็น
รดน้ำต้นไม้ตอนเย็นคะทานตอนเช้าเปิดตื่น
นอนมาบางทีก็ลืมหรือว่าแบบอ๋อขี้เกียจ
แต่พอช่วงเย็นๆสักเริ่ม 4 โมงเงี้ย 4 โมง
เย็นก็เริ่มคิดเรามีต้นไม้โอเคเดินเดิน
เดินออกมาแล้วก็มีบัวใช่ไหมแล้วก็รดน้ำ
ต้นไม้ตอนเย็น
ก็เลยคิดว่าเป็นอย่างนึงนะที่คนไทยเนี่ย
ชอบทำตอนเย็น
ก็ตอนเย็นเนี่ย
เลิกงานแล้วก็ออกไปเที่ยวไงคะครูฟ้าไป
เดินห้างเดินไม่เดินซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตนะคะ
นักเรียนเดินที่ช็อปปิ้ง Center ที่ห้าง
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีห้างใช่ไหมอาจจะเป็น
ภาระก้น
เดอะมอลล์เซ็นทรัล Terminal
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะห้างก็จะแบบมีหลายๆชั้นเนาะอาจจะ
สัก
1  2  3  4  5  6  6 ชั้นเพราะทำงาน
เสร็จเลิกงานหรือว่าช่วงซัก 15:00 น 16:00
นก็กำลังจะออกจากบ้านแล้วก็ไปเดินห้างตอน
เย็นๆอาจจะไปดูเสื้อผ้าไปกินอาหารเอาไป
กินอาหารก็เหมือนกันนะไปห้างตอนเย็น
[เพลง]
ก็จริงๆห้างก็ไปเช้าไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าเขาเปิด 10 โมงเช้า
แล้วนะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าถ้าเราไม่ทำงานน่ะวันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์บางทีเราก็แบบโอ๊ยตื่นสายอาบ
น้ำกว่าจะออกจากบ้านก็เย็นแล้วก็ไปเดิน
ห้างไปกินอาหารเย็นไปกินข้าวแล้วก็ไปเดิน
ห้างไปซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตอะไรเนี่ยคนไทยก็จะ
ชอบไปตอนเย็นๆไปเที่ยวห้างหรือถ้าไม่ใช่
ห้างก็จะไปเที่ยวแบบเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
เที่ยวกลางคืนหรอ
เที่ยวกลางคืน
เพราะว่าอย่างประเทศไทยจะมี Night  market
ใช่ไหมคะ
Night  market เปิด 4 โมงเย็นนะ
4 โมงเย็นเนี่ยเปิดคิดว่าถึงประมาณ
5 ทุ่มไหม
[เพลง]
ยังไม่มีคนไปนะคะเราจะไปไนท์มาร์เก็ต
ประมาณสัก 5 โมง
6 โมงก็คือไปเที่ยวเหมือนกันไปเดิน
ไนท์มาเก็ตจนถึงตอนกลางคืนเพราะว่าตอน
เย็น 5  4 โมง 5 โมง 6 โมงเนี่ยมันไม่
ร้อน
ก็เลยเดินได้คือมันก็ชื่อว่า Night
Market
ตอนกลางคืนนะคะแล้วก็
มันโอเคนะคะ
เพราะว่ามันเย็น
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยบ้านอยู่พัทยาแต่เวลาครูฝึก
อันนี้ PTT นะคะพัทยา
แต่เวลาครูฟ้ามากรุงเทพฯครูฟ้าชอบไปเดิน
ตลาดกลางคืนชอบไปเดินไนท์มาร์เก็ตมากๆ
ใช่ค่ะอาหารอร่อยแล้วก็มีเสื้อผ้านะคะ
แฟชั่นขายราคาราคาไม่แพง
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็บางคนทำงานเสร็จเลิกงานแล้ว
ก็ไปเดินได้ไม่ต้องคิดถ้าตอนเที่ยงเบรค 1
ชั่วโมงอย่างนี้มันก็เดินไปเดินในตลาดได้
ที่ไม่ใช่ไนท์มาร์เก็ตนะคะแต่มันมีเวลา
น้อยไงถ้าเป็นตอนเย็นเนี่ยมีเวลามากๆเดิน
ได้แบบสบายๆ
แต่ถ้าเป็นครูฟ้าน่ะครูฟ้าชอบทำอะไรตอน
เย็นมากที่สุดครูฟ้าน่ะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะชอบ
ทำอะไรตอนเย็นครูฟ้าเป็นคนชอบตอนเย็นนะคะ
นักเรียน
ตอนนี้ก็ยังชอบอยู่นะคะตอนเย็น
ครูฟ้าชอบทำทุกอย่างตอนเย็นเวลาที่พอตอน
เย็นใช่ไหมครูบาก็จะเล่นเกมนะคะอ่าน
หนังสือ
วาดรูปกินขนม
กินข้าว
ทำทุกอย่างคือตอนเช้าตอนกลางวันนอน
ตอนเย็นตื่นนอนเราก็เลยทำทุกอย่างตอนเย็น
ใช่ค่ะดูซีรีย์ด้วย
สายแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนชอบทำอะไร
ตอนเย็นเหมือนที่ครูกับครูฟ้าพูดให้ฟัง
หรือเปล่าหรือว่าไม่เหมือนก็ comment คุย
กันได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เราสองคนไปก่อน
เนาะเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะ